hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the park now we're
about to go in this witch's mouth and I
wanted to say that without sounding
sexual in any way and I think I
accomplished my goal so let's go
charging in there and go right down the
gullet now that I have a flashlight
anyway oh hey that's a new loading
screen and I didn't even know that we
needed a loading screen considering
we've kind of all been fluid so what's
going on in the witch's mouth house
mouth house house mouth mouth mouth
house oh is this where the Nexus 4 dark
energies is oh is this where most of the
scares are it's been pretty good about
the scares there's been a few things
like Chad wasn't too terribly scary but
I'm eager to see what else we got here
oh yes ooh yes now I can't tell if it
was all designed this way or if it's
actually a reason for this done Atlantic
Park Island has closed its gazed a
jeering throng of town folk gathered as
we hung the heavy iron padlock on the
gates small-minded fools scared of what
they don't understand my machines lie
silent and dejected but not beaten I've
sent my wife and son back to Boston I
have retreated here to the house of
horrors I must think so your wife and
your son don't think it's weird that
you're hanging out in the house of
horrors in your own custom little park
here little bizarre hi Chad
how you doing that the Slenderman that
is that that's the Slenderman that is
the Slenderman why is the Slenderman in
here what's going on here oh I like this
I mean I hope it's not just a cliche
like that because the Slenderman had a
bad habit of stealing children away as
well also you look like the monstrosity
that I meant and the person I met at the
front gate
that's bad Sims I like I like a lot okay
bene whoa hello now that looks more like
a werewolf skin rug than just a wolf
skin rug very bizarre okay
carrying on Oh cattle um leave me alone
leave me alone why did I come charging
in after Cal in the fall I wanted to see
okay it's gonna be like why what are
your guns powered by your own breath
what is that he's got he's got breath
powered guns I'm not even exaggerating
that's literally what they are okay bye
[Music]
oh you're very scary very scary okay
hello
how am I looking I'm looking good also
my eyes look rather dead and barren but
okay Oh huh that's peculiar how's it
going there gonna be something to do
with these reflections in here somewhere
that looks not fun okay god I'm gonna
see something behind me aren't I hello
what are you doing nothing here no not
worth reading okay okay apparently a
whole lot of nothing
[Music]
Oh Chad goddamn it Chad it's not being a
sack of and get out here come on
now Chad you know it'll take more than
that are you a Nazi vampire or something
like that show yourself show yourself
Callum oh hello what have you done with
him huh okay can I get down there it's
gonna be something to do with the
mirrors some reason there's so many
mirrors okay I mean other than the fact
that it is indeed a haunted house which
it is I know it is so obviously they
would okay so it was back here right
wasn't it here ah there we go shadow
hello who was that oh god damn it of
course you sack of you didn't you didn't
get me that's a lie you're a lying I'm
lying Oh blood that is a that is a
conspicuous amount of blood oh no wait
that's not blood that's just a broken
floor Jesus Oh
okay bye I'm still confused I've had no
intelligent commentary this entire time
because I've been waiting eagerly for
something to happen yet nothing really
has okay I guess I just carry on to
follow can you let me in please
is this his hidey-hole for the dark
nexus of energy okay
draw yourself maybe I don't know if I
want you to I don't know
nightmares circus a circus burns to the
ground on opening line at night killing
dozens the owner has put to death by an
enraged mob of town folk just as he
shouts out a curse now Raven a dark
sould wanderer comes to the ruins at
dusk in search of his missing mother let
the show begin
well that's kind of the opposite of
what's happening over here I wonder if
that's intention to they let me out
it gave me Calum back and sent me home
with a handful of breadcrumbs home
bitter sweet home I barely recognized it
weather had been color and light were
shadows and regrets weather had been
warmth there was a bone deep coldness
that never went away
I tried my hardest to keep the ghosts at
bay dawn watching from the dusty corners
while I tried to teach his son to read
my father coldly assessing me and
finding me lacking I devoted myself to
Calum did the things that they told me
it will get better they said every day
will be a little better than the last
I'm in the woods now Austen afraid
things never got any better wait did you
say dawn wait did I did I miss hear
something there was that she said that
dawn was there but I thought Dawn's a
name of her dead boyfriend after
multiple attempts to collect payment we
regret to inform you that your service
has been disconnected or will be
disconnected shortly please do the
falling making payment blah blah blah
electricity okay weird
wait so there is this my house the
wilting yeah
Solar Flare chance of her exactly an
exotic dancer named Chancellor as the
key to saving the world again okay
little bizarre but uh-oh like it what's
that dentist
I'm guessing oh that's so sweet you
can't be that bad of a mother
it's a Rubik's Cube I could solve it oh
man it's hot nothing on there this is a
bunch of his stuff for some reason in
the bottom of this house of horrors so
this must all be this must all be in her
mind examine a wrench why do you need to
examine a wrench there's something over
here wait what's that ah there we go
bread groans drop off Calum remember to
drop off gallon electricity bill fix
faucet okay
okay I guess that's perfectly normal
nothing to be worried about that it's so
bizarre this took a turn like
thematically it took a turn going into
this house of horrors
pacing why's it changed all this stuff
Lorraine I received your letter and I'm
not surprised you ran off with your
father all those years ago then
disappeared off the edge of the map and
when I finally tracked you down refused
to answer any of my letters and now you
bribed to ask me for help I have another
family now in another life your father
was a horrible man I never get the years
that I wasted on him I loved you I truly
did but every year you grew more and
more like him you were his girl never
really mine
still I would have fought for custody if
you hadn't run away with him it broke my
heart but I needed to go on living I
can't let you back into my life without
picking open old wounds I'm sorry
Lorraine but I just can't do it maybe
one day will be easier and I can meet
Callum but not yet I'm not ready to
forgive you please don't contact me
again so that's her mother who in this
letter is obviously a bit of a terrible
person because you can't blame someone
for growing up a certain way they are
who they are that's horrible and she ran
away she didn't even give a chance oh
that's that's that's a terrible letter
it's a terrible person miss maellard as
we agree in our meeting today you would
consider you fully recovered from your
illness this letter of official
notification that you were considered
sound of mind and body may return to
work at any time please note that you
should discontinue any medication that
you have been using and dispose of any
remaining medicine if you feel at any
times your suffering a relapse and
please make contact with your local
physician immediately oh so that
explains the hospital and possibly the
you know the electrocution if it was
electroshock therapy which I don't even
think is used anymore or shouldn't be
any way then that's fascinating the rain
seems to be suffering from depression
that began early in the pregnancy our
discussions amazing obviously these
episodes stem from the grief of losing
your partner dawn who died about six
months ago
there are several unresolved issues with
her father after being kept under
careful observation we provided standard
treatment for this disorder including
electro convulsion therapy the patient
responded and made allow rapid recovery
yeah feel better or else we'll shock you
I don't know if that's even remotely
good okay so so she was on medication
for depression most likely she tried to
kill herself at some point I can't in
quite figured out though indeed a state
of mr. Donald Williams has been
completed we regret to inform you that
the primary beneficiaries of his estate
including the life insurance settlement
for accidental death were listed as rose
Williams and Richard Williams of New
York State the deceased parents our
agency made contact with mr. and mrs.
Williams explained your situation
especially as regards to the birth of
Donaldson Callum unfortunately they were
not receptive of our overtures and they
specified that without any legal proof
of a biological relationship they
consider you ineligible to receive any
of the monies from Donald's estate they
asked if we no longer contact them
regarding this matter I understand this
may have a negative impact on your
current financial situations and I hope
I'm not being too forward when I enclose
the bill for our services with this
letter wow that is just really shitty
man oh man people suck people just suck
why is that door glowing Oh God
it's a Petey situation more pills I
don't know if I should even take those
after what happened last time no there's
a teddy bear
Lorraine thinks are right between us at
the moment I know I want to try and
explain it I think it's because I'm so
far for a moment working so hard every
day working at the park that gets worse
like a spring inside my mind whining
tighter and tighter and tighter when we
go for drinks after work it gets a
little better the guys relax and we
laugh and we're good people again I
don't want to come home to you without
being in my right mind but when this job
is done we need to get out of this place
we need to go back to the city where I
don't feel like this anymore
I love you Donald I was thinking about
names for boys and girls
I like Calum for a boy and Emma if it's
a girl oh that's so sad
oh hi Caleb Caleb I see you over there
let me see if there's any other notes
possibly up still there so say no Caleb
okay take the pills follow up organized
babysitter man yeah
what was going on on that radio
hello wine and spoiled food ah yes a
good year
continuing on you are very confused at
the moment
[Music]
Oh okay was that written by Callum
let's see same notices before right okay
III imagining this is gonna loop over
and over again and it's gonna get more
and more depressing as time goes on
sadder and sadder oh it's in disarray
now more bottles more pills whoa what
the hell happened
oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez oh geez
oh geez
Oh apples and Zoloft
oh so lift sorry tickets to Atlantic
island park okay Elise you remembered
about that even though this whole place
is in disrepair why is that in the
fridge okay why is that car on fire why
are they dying why are they alien
zombies oh geez so many questions
[Music]
okay man this game just took a turn oh
hey it's it's the guy okay but why and
also there's no door anymore I'm
guessing that was probably the final
level oh there's more oh there is more
babies hanging from the ceiling
whoo whoo Nellie whoo whoo Nellie whoo
baby got putting time out over there
whoo maybe got put to bed whoo baby
needs his diaper changed
hello is that dawn oh what a handsome
feller my two best friends Don and Laura
oh oh oh
babies baby solve the Rubik's Cube whoa
side ho was that say bye say bye bye to
say her could see her cry see her try
see your lie see her why I don't know
you're trying to say here okay all right
baby
little black eyed baby Oh baby head oh
he's an ass whoa baby's a drinking
problem
Oh baby's just tired whoa baby turn
didn't as Oh lift oh man there's a lot
of babies oh you are alone nobody loves
you Callum it's no longer who he once
was Oh baby for dinner
Oh baby needs a little more time in the
oven apparently her baby in here there's
an ice pick
won't know that bottles of blood those
bottles of blood might be bottles of
blood okay so I can't go through here
gotta go through this door
are there more babies over here which
way okay okay
whoo geez hey stop that you're letting
in a draft oh boy more babies Oh baby's
trying to avoid watching TV babies just
trying to get through the day oh boy oh
man oh babies for storage boy something
to say the least
is there another level to go down
another level oh wait hang on was there
another part of the letter over here
there was another letter right no
apparently it's gone or it's been oh
it's been burned Oh baby needs a
cigarette Oh baby had a long day at work
baby just needs to relax all right
carrying down another level I'm sure
this one's gonna go so good oh good even
more even more my goodness mud where'd
all the babies go all the babies seem to
have been replaced with blood oh no
there's blood on that that's not good
just say now see her die ask her wise
see her try see her lie see him die well
that's about all oh oh hi hey whoo
oh oh oh hi what is with that wasn't
with that face well okay what am I
looking at here
Oh baby God baby got overcooked
you will watch me rot oh ok ok alright
ok well then hold on hold on oh how
lovely
stories are told again and again and
from their shape we build our
understanding of the world huh -
children are led into the woods they are
lost for a time but then are captured by
an old witch the child goes missing in
Atlantic Island Park he wanders lost for
a time before finding his way into the
mouth of an old witch in the oldest
version of this story mother in the
which were the same person
I never wanted to be the witch I don't
know maybe kids broke in today it's been
a long time since I heard laughter so
very long I took one of them I kept now
myself it was fast the others didn't
notice I liked hearing him laugh the boy
from the Academy I put him on a slab I
tickled him until he couldn't breathe my
machines came to life whirring in time
with his gasps and shrieks I think this
is delightful the changed rod and me by
the machines is not yet complete there
must be other children I can lay on oh
you were murdering is this where all the
children have gone missing oh that makes
sense now that makes horrible horrible
sense eyes without sparkle I don't know
what that means
oh boy oh boy is reaching a crescendo
here examine bow we've reached a dead
end that's that's good Hansel and Gretel
of course it's all come back so that's
why it was so important that the tail in
the
The Swan Lake thing that's why it was so
important that that's what it was oh
okay god I don't want secured me Oh
stairs candle
[Music]
hi hey Chad oh good a shirt of cthulhu
perfect do I need a QuickTime event here
sometime soon
no no no how about no how about a whole
lot of No
can I can I fight this I have a choice
[Music]
hey Lorraine Lorraine
don't blame yourself Lorraine people
lose things all the time take a deep
breath and think about the last place
you saw your son
[Music]
in my heart and mind I always return to
Atlantic Island Park
[Music]
I don't know what the hell was that man
these games constantly leaving their
endings open up to interpretation ah
come on I'm trying to piece it together
in my mind so what what I'm confused by
is that guy at the end there that was
mr. winter but was mr. winter really
that she seemed to be in a police
interrogation room that seemed to be mr.
winter Atlanta Guilin Park so what's
real that's the question that I have on
my mind what is actually real here
what's the truth what is the truth of
the matter and what's just in her mind
what is fake what's what's what what is
the thing that her mind has been led to
interpretation and what is the truth the
truth of the matter is I feel at its
most basic she lost her boyfriend dawn
she lost dawn she had a child Caleb and
she regretted that child because that
child was a burden on her life and I
believe I believe at the end of that
what it's trying to say is that she
killed Caleb she did and in that police
interrogation room she has said that she
has lost her child and that whole
journey through the park was her
battling with herself
finding child begging for him to come
back in that she regretted her action
and yet
that is what she did that's my
interpretation of what that is I may be
wrong but that's the only conclusion I
can draw from based on what it's showed
me but I don't know how true is that was
the bark even a real thing maybe the
part was a real thing but you know she
always regretted the park because it's
where Don died man so like I don't know
what to make of it how close am I is
there a right answer out there
has it been explained how what a wild
ride I guess that's just the way it is
at the park so anyway that is the full
playthrough of the park it's shorter
than I thought it'd be but man that was
a wild ride so I need some time to
process this but thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
think of it down the comments below and
if you have a better interpretation of
what this ending means and what this
story means let me know I want to hear
the thoughts so thanks again everybody
so much for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye